r
bientôt parce qu'on va les
démolir.Jacques Bissonnet.
♪ ♪ ♪
Le minirail : un petit train
cher aux Montréalais et
Québecois, qui rappelle de bons
souvenirs.
- C'était facile de faire
le tour. Et je trouvais ça bien.
C'était lent. T'avais le temps
d'observer tou...
Non, c'était bien.
- Mais c'est quand même
des bons souvenirs, ça?
- Oui, oui. C'est des beaux
souvenirs, en effet.
- Vouss s s souvenez de quoi
particulièrement?
- Toute l'ambiance de l'Expo.
Et puis, la vision qu'on avait
aussi de plus haut que la terre.
C'était très agréable.
♪ ♪ ♪
- inininirail a été installé
pour l'Expo 67. C'était en fait
un métro de surface qui reliait
la Cité-du-Havre et les
pavillons de l'Île Sainte-HélèÎ.
Après l'Expo 67, eh bien,
le Minirail est devenu une
des attractions de la Ronde.
Il a circulé jusqu'en 2019,
pour ensuite être abandonné
lors de la pandémie.
Pour des raisons de sécurité,
la direction du parc a décidé
de le démolir.
JULIE BÉLANGER, spécialiste
de l'Exposition universelle
- C'est un petit peu un livre
qui se ferme. La fin de quelque
chose avec la disparition du
dernier circuit et des dssss
trains.
- Le Minirail a été construit
en Suisse. Il n'était donc pas
neuf à l'Expo 67.
- Il y a deux choses, en fait,
que l'équipe de Drapeau et
l'organisation de l'Expo a
acheté, suite à l'exposition
de Lausanne en 64 : le Miniral
et la Spirale.
- Il y a peut-être des enjeuxéc.
C'est quelque chose peut-être...
désuétude technologique. Ça fait
longtemps qu'il existe, donc
peut-être qu'il y a quelque
chose de mieux aujourd'hui,
de plus sécuritaire.
- L'organisme Héritage Expo 67,
qui veut préserver la mémoire
du Minirail, vient de demander
à l'Expo Rail de Saint-Constant,
le musée ferroviare canadien,
de mettre la main sur quelques
wagons.
- L'urgence, c'était vraiment
de préserver quelques trains
avant qu'ils partent pour
la ferraille.
♪ ♪ ♪
Une partie du Minirail risque
donc de se retrouver au
histoire de nous rappeler
de bons moments.
Ici Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.
♪ ♪ ♪